all right we're doing the California
Standards released questions in geometry
now and here's the first question and it
says which of the following best
describes deductive reasoning and I'm
not a huge fan of when they ask
essentially definitional questions in
math class but we'll do it and hopefully
I'll help you understand what deductive
reasoning is although I do think that
you've probably deductive reasoning
itself is probably more natural than the
definition they'll give here but let's
well actually before I even look at the
definitions let me just tell you what it
is and then we can see which of these
definitions matches it deductive
reasoning is if I give you a bunch of
statements and then from those
statements you deduce or you come to
some conclusions that you know must be
true like if I said that you know all
all boys are tall if I told you all boys
are tall and if I told you that bill is
a boy bill is a boy that's two separate
words oh and boy so if you say okay if
these two statements are true what can
you deduce well I can say well bill is a
boy and all boys are tall then bill must
be tall you deduced this last statement
from these two other statements that you
knew or two and this one has to be true
if those are tortures that bill must be
tall that is deductive reasoning
deductive reasoning not must be tall
right not bill must be deductive so
anyway you you have some statements and
you deduce other statements that are
actually must be true given those and
you often hear this you know the
opposite of it not the opposite but
another type of reasoning is inductive
reasoning and that's when you're given a
couple of examples and you generalize
you know if I said that well I don't
want to get too complicated here we
because this is a question of deductive
reasoning but it's essentially I mean
you know generalizations often aren't a
good thing but if you if you you see a
couple of examples and you see a pattern
there you can often extrapolate and get
to a kind of a broader generalization
that's inductive reasoning but that's
not what they're asking us about this
let's see let's see if we could find the
definition of deductive reasoning in
in the California Standards language so
use a logic use logic to draw
conclusions based on accepted statements
yeah well actually that sounds about
right that's what we did here we use
logic to draw conclusions based on
acceptance statements which were those
two so I'm gonna go with a so far
let's see accepting the meaning of a
term without definition well I don't
even know how one can do that how do you
accept the meaning of something without
it having being defined let's see so
it's not B I don't think anything is
really B C defining mathematical terms
to correspond with physical objects oh
no that's that's not really anything
related to deductive reasoning
D inferring a general truth by examining
a number of specific examples well this
is actually this is more of what what I
just talked about inductive reasoning so
they want to know what the duct of
reasoning is so I'm going to go with a
use use logic to draw conclusions based
on accepted statements next problem
next problem okay let me copy and paste
the whole thing as copy and paste is
essential with these geometry problems
I won't have to redraw everything okay
in the diagram below angle 1 and this
right here will just you should learn
means congruent and when you say to
congruence are well when you say two
angles are congruent so in this case
they're saying angle 1 is congruent to
angle 4 that means that they have the
same angle measure and the only
difference why you know there's a
difference tree incongruent and being
equal is that you know congruence as
well they can have the same angle
measure but they could be in different
directions and they can you know they
though the Rays that come out from them
could be of different lengths and all
that although I'd often say that that's
equal as well but if we're dealing with
congruence that's what it means it
essentially just means the angle
measures are equal so we could draw that
here angle 1 is congruent to angle 4
which just means that these angle
measures are the same whether we're
measuring them in degrees or radians all
right now what do they want us to come
to conclusion which of the following
conclusions does not have to be true
does not have to be true not angles 3 &
4 supplementary angles so what a
supplementary mean that means that angle
3 plus angle 4 have to be equal to 180
this is this is a definition of a
supplementary angle supplementary if you
like I added a supplementary right
supplementary so angles 3 & 4 they're
actually opposite angles and you could
play with these if you if you had these
two lines and you kind of change the
angle which they intersect you would see
that angles 3 & 4 are actually going to
be congruent angles they're always going
to be equal to each other and measure
right so they're equal to each other and
if angle 4 is you know let's say angle 4
we don't know what it is if angle 4 is
95 degrees and angle 3 is also going to
be 95 degrees if angle 4 is 30 degrees
angle 3 is also going to be 30 degrees
so I can think of a bunch of cases where
this will not be equal to 180 that's the
only way that this would be equal to 180
angle 3 plus angle 4 is if angle 4 were
a 90-degree angle and angle 3 we're also
a 90-degree angle but they don't tell us
that all they tell us is that angle 4
and angle 1 are the same at least when
you measure the angles so I would
already go with choice a that does not
have to be true that will only be true
if both of those angles are 90 degrees
let's see line line L is parallel to
line m yep that's true if that angle is
equal to this angle the best way to
think about it is this angle is also
equal to and you could watch the videos
on the angle game that I do we go we do
this quite a bit but opposite angles are
equal and that should be intuitive to
you at this point because you can you
can imagine that if these these two
lines if I were to change the angle
which they cross no matter what angle I
do it at that's always going to be equal
to this so angle 1 is going to be
congruent to angle 2 and then if these
two lines are parallel if L and M are
parallel then 2 & 4 are going to be the
same or you can think of it the other
way if 4 and 1 are the same and 1 is the
same as 2 then that means 4 is the same
as 2 and a 4 & 2 are the same then that
means that these two lines are parallel
so these this is definitely true angle 1
is congruent to angle 3 angle 1 well
once again if angle 1 is congruent to
angle 4 right so those two are congruent
and angle 3 is congruent to angle 4
because there are opposite angles or you
know instead of staying congruent I
could say equal then angle 3 is also
going to be congruent if this is equal
to this and this is equal to this then
this is equal to that alright and then
the last one 2 is congruent to 3 2 is
congruent to 3 well by the same logic if
1 if 1 is equal is congruent to 4 and
since 1 & 2 are opposites it's also the
same as 2 & 4 is because it's opposite
of 3 it's congruent to that all of these
angles have to be the same thing so 2 &
3 would also be congruent angles so all
of the other ones must be true BC and D
so a is definitely our choice next
problem the next problem
let me copy and paste it okay okay
consider the arguments below every
multiple of 4 is even 376 is a multiple
of 4 therefore 376 is even fair enough a
number can be written as a repeating
decimal if it is rational pi cannot be
written as a repeating decimal therefore
pi is not rational which ones if any use
deductive reasoning
ok so statement 1 every multiple of 4 is
even 300 676 is a multiple of 4 so that
so this is deductive reasoning right
because you know that they say every
multiple of 4 is even so you pick any
multiple of 4 is going to be even 376 is
a multiple 4 therefore it has to be even
so this is correct logic so statement 1
is definitely a deductive reasoning
let's see statement number 2 a number
can be written as a repeating decimal if
it is rational so if you're rational
that if you're rational that means
then you can write it as a repeating
decimal repeating decimal that's like
point three three three three two three
right that's one third that's all they
mean by repeating decimal right but
notice this statement right here number
can be written as a repeating decimal if
it is rational that doesn't say that it
doesn't say that a repeating decimal
means that it's rational it just means
that a rational number can be written as
a repeating decimal this statement
doesn't let us go the other way it
doesn't say that a repeating decimal can
definitely be written as a rational
number it just says that if you are
rational if it is rational a number can
be written as a repeating decimal fair
enough and then it says pi cannot be
written as a repeating decimal pi cannot
be written as a repeating decimal so if
pi cannot be written as a repeating
decimal can pi be rational well if pi
was rational if pi was in this set if pi
were it rational then we could it would
be you could write it as a repeating
decimal but it says that you cannot
write it as a repeating decimal so
therefore pi cannot be rational cannot
be in the set of rationals so therefore
this is also sound deductive reasoning
so both 1/n to use deductive reasoning
as far as I know let's see next problem
actually I'm out of time see you in the
next video